the bitcoin network is a decentralized
payment system all kinds of people have
opinions there's controversy there's
debate there's critiques but it doesn't
matter at the end of the day because the
bitcoin network is a decentralized
payment system that allows you to send
very very very large sums of money for
basically nothing what do i mean if i
was go to the bank today and i said hey
i need to send a wire let's say i got
you know real big boy wire i need to
make i need to make a hundred k or a
million dollars and i need to wire that
to somebody they'll tell me hey you got
to pay 25 bucks maybe 50 depending on
what the fees uh that your bank charges
for wires are so if i want to send
anything from a hundred thousand dollars
let's say all the way down if i just
want to send a 50 wire they're going to
charge me 25 bucks it's a flat fee let's
go well bitcoin says that doesn't make a
ton of sense so there is a new reddit
post that we found today as you can see
from the screenshot the best business
show research team we are real time we
don't play around over here we're real
time research team we found this 14
minutes after the post 14 minutes
record time let's rock and roll the
research team don't play around two one
billion dollar bitcoin transactions were
sent over the last two days for a
combined fee of 19 mil uh 19 that's it
both of them also drastically overpaid
for the fees that they had to pay so
these people said you know what i really
need this to get there immediately i'm
willing to pay more fees to speed it up
get it there faster they paid
to send over two billion dollars you
bank can't do that boomers so if we go
and we look at the actual post itself it
says this is the second largest bitcoin
transaction in history the transaction
was first broadcast to the bitcoin
network on august 27 2021 at 1am gmt
plus 5 30 at the time of the transaction
22
249 bitcoin was sent for a value of over
1 billion 1 billion 41 million 621 432
dollars look at your boy out here
reading it like i'm thomas edison high
priority fee at this time was only 11
cents they only had to pay 11 cents to
send a billion forty one million six
hundred twenty one thousand four hundred
and thirty two dollars
instead they said you know what
we're gonna send a billion dollars we
got cash and so they paid nine dollars
instead that is less than fifty percent
what your bank would have charged you
and by the way your bank wouldn't let
you send a billion dollar wire like this
at 1am so this first transaction we have
the actual transaction information here
the reason why this is interesting i
know it's dark it's okay put your
glasses on turn the brightness on your
computer up or your tv you could see it
i promise
what is important about this is the fact
that you can actually see this
information
how can you not be impressed by the fact
that you can literally look at the
transaction itself
and you can see the inputs and the
outputs you can see the fee paid you can
see the actual timestamp you can see so
much information about this
but it's all pseudonymous we have no
clue who owns the
wallet that is initiating it and the
wallet that is receiving it it is a
pseudonymous system
that is still a public ledger it allows
us to verify that this transaction
actually occurred pretty damn cool when
you start to think of a public ledger
decentralized payment system that allows
somebody to send a billion dollars for
what could have been as low as 11 cents
said they paid nine dollars now if we go
back to the reddit post and we see the
second post is this is the fourth
largest bitcoin transaction in history
that happened on august 29th
and this transaction was first broadcast
to the bitcoin network on august 29 2021
at 11 43 pm gmt plus 5 30 at the time of
this transaction 20 784 bitcoin was sent
with a value of 1 billion 12 million 845
0807
thomas edison right there for you why
thomas edison because i said so the high
priority fee at the time was only 13
cents but the sender paid 10.62
or 10.62 fee the bitcoin network is
casually moving billion dollar
transactions with instant settlement
confirmation this is quite amazing the
reddit user who posted this is my eyes
don't work because i'm getting old is
simple lifestyle shout out to you we
found your stuff in 14 minutes shout out
to us now the reason why this is so
fascinating is if we go to the second
transaction again what can we see we can
see the inputs and the outputs we can
see exactly which wallet it came from we
could see which wallet it went to we can
see what the amount was we can see the
timestamp we can see the fee paid
incredible when you start to think of a
decentralized payment system that has
this pseudo-anonymous transparency where
anyone in the world can go and see this
transaction see a lot of information
about it by the way it's not just the
big transactions it's not just billion
dollar transactions you can go all the
way back to january 3rd 2009 see every
single transaction that has ever
occurred in this payment system this is
the beauty of bitcoin this is why this
system is superior to every other system
in the world and this is why i believe
that the bitcoin network is going to
become the global payment system that
everyone is ultimately going to end up
using
thoughts from the two geniuses on the
other side of the room shows the power
of bitcoin of the network the uh i was
looking it up earlier and so everyone
knows that there's a standard kind of 25
to 40 to 50 fee that gets applied to a
wire transfer uh whether it's domestic
or international but i was also reading
that they can make up to banks i'm
talking about can make up to like a
quarter of a percentage point up to five
percentage points on a wire based on how
long they float the current float the uh
the money for right so how long it takes
them to actually deliver the money they
lend it out overnight and make interest
on it and then the exchange conversion
rate on the other end so some of these
some of these uh wire transfers banks
are making up to five percent on which
is absolutely ridiculous uh that's
obviously on the high case but even at a
quarter of a percent is still high
compared to the fees that you're seeing
on these billion dollar transactions to
send two billion dollars of money and
paid 19
is absurd you could you could spend a
send a wire for a thousand dollars and
pay more than that in a fee to be
clear if you didn't overpay for the fees
it would have been even cheaper it would
have been less
than a 25 cent piece of bubble gum out
of a bubble gum machine
[Laughter]
think about that for a second right is
you could have sent two billion dollars
using the bitcoin network
for less than putting a quarter in the
bubble gum machine that is the future of
finance that is the future of payment
systems and the open networks are going
to win there is no way in the world
that anyone can compete with that and by
the way whether it was a billion dollars
or they wanted to send 25 cents and only
pay the 11 cent fee there's no bank in
the world that would allow you to wire
25 cents it is a superior system that's
what we're watching right john
yeah this is sick
i sent a wire the other day i paid 30
for it
and it wasn't very big wire so
um yeah the transparency the speed um
and the convenience and fee of it is
awesome like you said you can't send a
wire at 1am really like to do that you
have to get verification from your bank
beforehand like all this other stuff um
it's awesome i mean i tried to send a
wire the other day and i had to go into
the bank i had to got there at 9 00 a.m
they opened at 9 00 a.m and i still had
to wait so have you all ever heard the
story of uh giannis antetokounmpo and
how he sent money with western union no
again i know we held the funeral for
western union so they're done
there's no more talking about them
necessarily but when he got to the
states he was essentially taking all of
his rookie money and he was sending it
back home to his family and he went to
western union before a game and he did
this all the time where he would go and
he would send money back and one time he
sent more than he had he accidentally he
says sent essentially everything that
was in his account at the time maybe he
had a couple accounts or whatever it was
but he emptied out his account and sent
it through western union on a wire he
didn't have enough money to get uh to
get back into uh he took a cab there he
didn't have enough money to take a cab
back to the stadium for a game so he
started running to the stadium a fan saw
him on the side of the road you know a
seven footer running and was like hey
what are you doing said i'm going to the
stadium picked him up and drove him to
the stadium that's wild but think about
this with this kind of system right he
can do it essentially for free from his
phone in the locker room really right
like or from sitting on the toilet yeah
my point really is that he doesn't need
to drive to western union worry about
sending all of his money there then have
to pay the fee then have to realize he
doesn't have any more money then have to
get in a cab and run and do all these
other things right just makes it so much
simpler from that perspective to send
money to people in other countries
on top of that uh john joe myself most
of you at home when you go to send a
wire
there are limits so if you ever have to
send a certain amount
right you have to go into the physical
bank and uh
i think it's safe to say
the people that you interact with and
the process you interact with
is absurd in 2021 and then you lay on
top of that not only is there hours of
operations for the bank
but uh you also have to get the wire
information in by a certain time if
you're on the west coast
at 4 pm
if you give them the wire information in
most cases they don't send the wire till
the next day
yeah we're supposed to be working i got
to pay somebody i can't do it
hours of operations is stupid it's 20
21. you have the internet what's going
on here on top of that
today at 5 00 p.m when the banks close
it's over you can't do this
until tuesday
why because monday's a holiday and they
ain't working either the bankers are
lazy the computers aren't lazy
the computers always are on the
computers are always running and if the
computers are always on the financial
system should always be on but you are
not allowed to access your funds or move
large amounts of money in the legacy
system unless somebody who has a suit
tie and wears cologne tells you you can
do it and they establish hours of
operation let's go
someone made a joshua in the comments
made a good point he was like even the
fact that you even have to say why
you're pulling out your money is a
problem right like if if they ask where
the wire's going you have to tell them
all this kind of stuff they have to
approve you yeah say are you allowed to
send your money you know what happened
last time that i went there i the last
time i sent a wire this is no joke they
i opened my bank account when i was uh
15 years old i believe 15 years old oh
joey bags you're getting you're securing
the baggage i got i gotta go 15. we had
a 12 year old he ain't got a bank
account he got four i had three years on
him in three years he's got to put
somewhere to get his uh his millions in
there uh so i opened the bank account
when i was like 15 maybe it was 16
whatever but i was young and i go there
and they we fill out the whole wire
thing i wait for an hour and a half then
i do it it takes forever all this stuff
right then when we're done the last step
is signing the form so i signed the form
and the guy comes back and he goes sir
we're not gonna be able to do this for
you actually i said why not
he hits me with your signature doesn't
match and i said what and he said when
you open your account this was your
signature this is your signature now i
said yeah dude i was 15 years old
like what so he literally gave me my old
signature had me look at it and said
recreate that uh this has happened to me
multiple times and i literally had to
like act like i'm an artist and remake
my signature when i was 14 years old and
i literally couldn't do it it was that
ridiculous so you could uh screw it
i'm like what dude
what's up guys bang bang thanks so much
for watching the best business show
today if we're gonna be the best
business show we obviously need the best
partner that's why the exclusive sponsor
the best business show is sofi they're
an all-in-one platform that allows you
to invest in all kinds of different
assets including stocks etfs crypto ipos
and they even have an automated
investing function if that's your thing
so before we start getting after it
again make sure that you go download
sofi you get an invest account and when
you make your first crypto trade
regardless of what you buy they'll give
you ten dollars in bitcoin for free it's
that simple head on over to sofi.com to
get started today thanks so much for
watching and i hope you come back and
watch more of the best business show
tomorrow
[Music]